just be careful right you'll notice I
haven't drawn my parallelogram or to you
and there's a reason why if I want to
consider said one takeaway is it - and
its modulus right when's that gonna go
on here well it's not gonna go into this
parallelogram at least not at first
not directly right it goes into a
different parallelogram or together do
you remember this one we had a look at
addition and subtraction and how they're
different
do you remember this is really this do
you remember that subtracting is adding
the negation okay so I really need to
get the negation on the picture key
which is going down in destruction new
casual changes okay no thing about this
right thing about that you forgot the
negation right negatives it's just
that's gonna be hitting rotation pi
radians down this way okay so we're
going down somewhere about there yes
yeah now remembering that this became
vector land right its trained to you
that this vector and this vector okay
where's my parallelogram now do you
remember it's gonna it's gonna be down
here
right it's gonna end up in the fourth
quadrant okay so let's draw that
parallelogram in okay now I'm gonna
pause there you should be able to draw
it in now is there 1 minus n 2 is and
you should be able to therefore put Z 1
minus Z 2 as a vector back up in the
first quarter we're in an inverted
commas where it belongs okay you do that
and then see if you can make this same
set of statements this same set of
inequalities for the triangle that you
produce okay where Z 1 minus Z 2 should
belong in this parallelogram right so
it's gonna be Z 1 and then give you your
negatives into vector which is why you
land here right so this this here is the
position
first of all - ed - because it's coming
from the origin UK with that but of
course
so you complete our triangle you've got
two choices right you got two choices
you can either take Zeb one - there to
consider the free vector of that as this
guy up here well certainly you could do
this trick that we had over here
consider the three vectors at - Andrew
here over to here because then they've
got same magnitude right now for reasons
that will become clear we'll see if we
get to this lesson well either get to it
this lesson or period - I think it's
actually gonna be more helpful to
consider this guy up here so I'm gonna
move cuz they're what - ed - I'm gonna
consider that free vector like I said
you'll get the same result either way
cuz you'll get the triangle with the
same signs in it but this will be more
useful to us long term so they're up in
the first quadrant I've got a dead one
Zed - Zed one takeaways into triangle
okay all right hand me some inequalities
what you got for me anyone let me start
you off how about uh how about this one
what can I say about this I can say this
is like this is like equivalent to this
one isn't it is the same statement it's
just a different side but it's still in
a triangle so I can still say that all
right give me another one
good and I've got one last one which is
this one
but with this M what is it - you swapped
okay like sir okay now haven't got these
on hand right again these are all true
these are not true
but which of these are most useful or
elegant to us
which one which one you try yeah yeah
that's fine that's okay that's okay
so you might notice you might notice
depending on the triangle that I draw
for instance remember I said over here
okay I'm zip what what said - is the
longest side in this triangle
do you remember I said that right but it
doesn't have to be the longest side of
the triangle I can think of a z1 and z2
that I've worked quite long but we'll
make z1 plus z2 really short okay
haven't he grant can you imagine such a
triangle let's just do the stuff with a
side I draw this right but just imagine
can you think of a simple pair of
complex numbers z1 is it true that when
you add them who make z1 plus z2 very
short how do you think it's not that
hard okay
all right so let's have a think about
saying if I go I'm sorry that was not
the number you suggested if I said 5
plus 6 that's okay yeah and 5 - you're
gonna these are conjugates right so this
these two imaginary part will disappear
so you're gonna get something over here
now hold on a second of it these are
still this guy's stupid me longer isn't
he because you're gonna get an isosceles
triangle okay
and this leg could be longer that's fine
right that was a different version but
this demo percent you still ended up one
try again can you give me always every
one plus it to the sum will be shorter
yeah make it a second number minus 5
minus 6
okay so alright so you put it over here
when I had these these are working again
I'm going to get here okay that's fine
can you give me a little just gonna make
an actual triangle come on it's not it's
not that hard let's take my dominance
Jeff sees a regional suggestion let's go
five plus six I like that what could I
add to this that would still give me a
triangle 2 minus 3i 2 minus 3i down here
is the one I'm trying to exhume 1 plus n
2 I'm trying to make it shorter I'm
trying to make it a shorter lightning
the truck 6 plus 2i 6 plus 2 I like that
is it gonna work think about the
parallelogram law oh no that's not gonna
work is it because 6 plus 2i that's
gonna be 11 plus 8i that's still gonna
go off in this direction we were on the
right track with the mayonnaise right
because the negatives are gonna make it
on the smaller right so let's rewind I
think I think you started to see it's
gonna have to be some way down here
right do you see that yeah so let me
come up with some something like okay
that's five let's make this minus 2
minus 3 up something like that okay I
just do the number don't think
geometrically yet just add these two
what's the real part 3
3 what's the imaginary part 3 + 3 + 3 I
so if that's 5 plus 6i then 3 plus 3
lights should be somewhere like this ish
okay you see that now let me consider
video that's a bad
yeah I still have established my point
which one which one shorter let me
consider the free vector of this guy
he's gonna belong with as throwaways in
a trick question I should be done here
and he's going to be the free vector of
minus 2 minus 3 on UK like that yeah so
he in in this spot here this third one
plus said - it's shorter that's a bit
weird because you're like adding things
but because you're adding something
that's negative right no wonder it ends
up being smaller now therefore though
does that break when I say over here
doesn't it doesn't it all does it
because I don't care which side is
longer right all of these are true no
matter you can say about the longest
side or the second longest side the
middle side or the short side it doesn't
matter the triangle inequality is still
true it's just that this one because it
gives me more interesting statement okay
so if I'm coming back to him we had a
point here right coming back to here I
feel like oh my length is shorter that's
okay in fact on my diagram blank is
probably slightly short up and it
doesn't whether whether the legs are
relatively shorter or longer does not
affect the truth or falsehood of any of
these statements okay which is why this
is my whole point of saying 1 2 3 I say
all of them textbooks often jump in and
they just say this one and they say I
haven't picked out which one's the most
interesting one yeah I will in a second
they just pick up that one makes it seem
as if this sharone's in not there all
true ok we just pick out one cuz it's
more interesting the same